this this embodies actually the first
time we're really doing general maths as
opposed to stuff that you boss
let me try and explain you've got the
sick child require medication and often
this is the case right
a child's medication is basically and
out for the patient they adjust the
dosage right so obviously you're small
that you don't need as lunch you've got
legal childhood sixteen months all it's
just a bit under one and a half and has
a massive that's a very very technical
area here she weighs seven point nine
years okay now what you have dosage is a
really important practical problem scary
thought one day a lot of you most of you
are you will become parents and this is
the kind of thing which you're trying to
work out now if you are lucky the bottle
that you're looking at will have all
these kinds of measurements on it
however all of that comes from
mathematics like all of that way what I
supposed to give my kids who gets better
but it doesn't end up involving you
everything back home because I've
overdosed it that all comes from this
lengthy okay and there's not just one
other again this is one of the things I
mean by way now this is general maths
this is not just stuff than you saw in
United ten okay you need to become
comfortable with the fact that in maths
in real life there's not just one answer
have a look at Part A B and C and how
they differ just look at them carefully
what do they each asked you what a B and
C let's let's do min of hoc keyword
thing here right let's do it compare and
contrast there's something that each one
is asking the same what is one three
those nice names
yeah you're looking for the child's
dosage okay looks that's all you want to
know right a B and C they asked the same
question but what's different if there
are three different rules named after
three different people freed young and
Clark right three different schemes for
yeah well what should the child's dosage
beef and that's the way real life is
there isn't just like one degree to
point B in the medical world in science
it's kind of like well we have different
ways of calculating this okay just like
what you guys something be my right you
guys know what being my
and you kind of roughly to had a
calculator I think it's what it's weight
on height squared I think you just pee
here that sounds right you might have
now that's one measure on like your
overall you know health weight ratio
Mecca is not the only one but there are
lots of difference and this sort of
pulls back the curtain it shows you
there's different ways of doing this so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna show you
would you ate ate together I'm gonna get
you to go to your B and C and then we
regret the rubber really hits the road
is Pardee that's I got my say about it
to general to see questions you have to
draw a conclusion we've got to say I've
got numbers but numbers are not the
answer the answer is what am I gonna do
about what am I gonna use those numbers
are coming an interpreter so write on a
a and let's do this one two go now
having unknown a in this exercise and it
give to start right from the beginning
the very first thing that I put down on
the whiteboard on the piece of paper is
the important information that I need
for these questions but it's not at all
obvious from the beginning like what
matters okay
for instance again look back over those
are three questions again they each talk
about different printables right but
what does turning rules mean you just
got out dosage the child's age and mass
but the pretty rose you gonna work out
which ones which and that's part of the
problem okay so I'm gonna write down
just in words what are the three
important numbers that appear in the
question let's go child H okay
childish by the way I'm going to put in
it's really including pretty important
I'm gonna put in not just the number but
also the unit like what if the question
is gonna ask me Yuma but I told that be
in my second ago right it's what I say
wait
a hat square but it kind of makes a
difference whether your height is in
centimeters or feet and inches or meters
I think I'll put on there in ten minutes
you'll obviously get a completely
different number and you'll think wow my
weights really really good and you know
it completely under way
so the U does matter you need to pay
attention to those six to eight months
what's something else it's important
question at all dosage yep okay great
question we will get to that in due time
I want to get the important information
first and then I would try and work out
I'll try to sort out what we'll know if
I'm actually doing last one chose mass
and the units are points four seven
point nine kilos it's more grams its lot
pounds its kilograms nice and metric
okay right now this is pot a so you can
see if they introduced a whole bunch of
different things differently that's
right and we need to sort out what's
what for instance when I see em I
immediately think em that looks like
mass right do you agree that would be a
common-sense thing to do except then you
read the question and that's not at all
what it means you're gonna what's it say
changing each of the infants so look
there's the age right there so I'm gonna
label that as M
does that make sense I'm trying to
clearly mention like people see phone
all the time and they just put the wrong
things in the wrong places which means
you get something completely nonsensical
at the end so there was M is a capital A
what's capital a about a dosage so
that's here okay then the last one you
might think this is well this must be D
right this is D because that's the last
thing that's left but it's not is it
what what is D
here's the infant dosage which I don't
actually know that's the thing I'm
trying to work out so in fact this the
child's mass in um in freeze rule in his
way of working out the child mass
doesn't come into play at all and that's
why you see people disagree over these
things
some people say yeah how happy they are
invaders and free doesn't mix oh okay
so therefore I've got all of the
variables that I need two inputs let's
actually solve this question I can say D
equals and I want to put my numbers in M
times a 16 times 20 divided by hundred
thirty okay now this is the substitution
that we looked at last lesson right so
for those of you who your honor yeah
we're just maybe should we slot in the
right numbers in the right spots in that
way substitution into mathematical 40
with it's like why is it a different
exercise it's just substitution and the
answer is it's all this stuff around it
if all the questions were asking after
the fact in the fourth okay I just run
out of space just the W what's the
actual numbers anyone or anything here
so okay so three is 450 will give me 32
over 15 however has not the most useful
yes of course but it's your 15 mils
someone yeah okay no I'm just going to
pause it again this is a general math
thing it's not just a journeyman thing
you are used to you like Tommy do you
want a fraction nice or whatever we can
kind of have to decide just like in the
real world right then um that's gonna be
useful to me it is well your calculator
hands you this done right I'm guessing
this isn't Mills because this was in
Mills
okay but guess what again as I like a
human being
trying to actually do something he on
know what this number is useful to me
what are you wrecking how much of this
number is useful I reckon obviously the
two that's the most significant agenda
so I'm gonna put an approximately equal
sign because natural project clearly the
two now immediately you guys don't have
a heap of amount of experience I expect
administering child medication so I will
give you a bit of a hand I'm sure this
is what an oral syringe looks like right
this is what you use to cute kids
medicine because of course they cuts all
the tablets because they're kids right
now you have a careful look at that how
far would you like me to go on this
number I reckon we could get point one
and I don't think you're gonna get any
accuracy after that like what is this no
bomb three hundredths of a meal in fact
the kid's gonna sneeze out 300 in the
middle anyway before you put it so
that's where I'm going to end the
question didn't tell you hey can you
give me the answer
give it to me the two significant
figures or to the nearest tenth of a
meal you just have to think about that
you have to think while doing your math
that's enough oh my dear is it
so that's right that's right boys that's
my love song I'll get back to the
question but you can see the question in
front of you as well Jim pop be a putz
even the process is very similar think
carefully about what party rules stand
for what numbers in the question and
then we'll come together we have a look
at pod date